peut-être
en décembre 2002 je suis allé en
argentine et c'était tout juste une
année après la grande manifestation
populaire qui relançait une nouvelle
phase dans l'histoire du pays une
manifestation de mécontentement lors de
mon voyage
j'ai vu la crise j'ai vu mon pays
effondré
je vu son avenir incertain
j'ai vu ses habitants la pauvreté et la
misère
j'ai vu non moins qu'il ne restait pas
les vrais croise et j'ai vu comment les
argentins ont continué à 20 c j'ai vu
comment il s'est mobilisé
comment une manifester j'ai vu les
drapeaux flottent et j'ai vu comment on
recherchait désespérément des solutions
alternatives
le rythme est l'une de ces alternatives
une 250 is in récupéré par ses souliers
initient des femmes qui travaillent
saint patron à notre gestion
maintenant beaucoup de gens nous
considèrent comme des ouvrières
dangereuse parce que nous avons goûté au
fruit interdit
nous savons première cook chaque petit
morceau de tissu qui composent un
costume chaque sou dépensé pour la
lumière nous savons tous et nous savons
qu'avec des prix accessibles aux clients
nous terrifie vrai conserver les usines
les patrons travail qu'on s'enrichit
alors que les ouvriers travaillent pour
vivre simplement dans le respect des
autres
palat évalué
que se passe-t-il exactement agric man
en quoi est elle différente des autres
usines textiles
nous sommes en train de mettre un peu
d'ambiance pour la fête parce qu'on est
un peu découragé nous allons faire un
tir par contre nous nous voulons être un
peu ensemble en souvenir du 18 décembre
de l'année dernière
je suis content parce qu on est ici
depuis un an déjà reine c'est pas rien
avec des répressions des expulsions mais
nous y sommes et là continue de
travailler
laurent
notamment
les 18 décembre 2001 les patrons avant
d'en lucine les ouvriers y reste en
attendant les retours pourraient payer
mais les patrons ne sont jamais revenus
ça a été le début du contrôle ouvrier
délice in bruckmann
j'avais l'année dernière
justement de cette fête aujourd'hui
on était trente personnes
mais pas trop faire tourner
allez
et beaucoup de charges lourdes depuis
cinq ans qu'ils nous payent comme ça un
peu et on peut pas en vivre
remettons-nous descente plus tôt après
nos entretiens à peine 5 6 2
on travaille de la même façon nous
faisons faut que les femmes rurales
faisait sa mort il n'ya plus les brutes
man ici il n'ya plus que nous maintenant
nous n'avons plus patron le patron c'est
nous mêmes
nous travaillons conserver un emploi et
ne pas être au chômage sans ressources
et
le banc dans notre production il usines
continuent de fonctionner
jacques est d'origine française
il vit en argentine depuis 50 ans
quand dinner in audi fait ce travail et
pas plus et on va vers autre chose entre
autres choses
vitry
ça n'a pas raté
son patron je travaille beaucoup plus
tranquille et j'apprends à faire les
choses que je ne savais pas faire avant
parce qu'avant tu connais tout essayé de
le disait et en rester là
maintenant c'est différent on apprend
des nouvelles choses changent
oh
à
est ce un patron les ouvriers continuent
de travailler sans théâtre
les inserts continue de lancer depuis
l'année 2000 en argentine les ouvriers
refusent de quitter les usines quand
celles ci sont déclarées en faillite au
cas ces propriétaires les abandonnent
les ouvriers choisi de continuer de
travailler après avoir supporté la
réduction de leurs salaires et la perte
de l'ensemble de leur couverture sociale
plus de 12000 au pied des 150 us in
réclament leurs salaires impayés
je crois que tout le monde veut
travailler et gagner son salaire pour
faire ce que l'on veut parce que son
travail un ouvrier sais rien
malheureusement en plus il doit acheter
ceci cela il doit manger si on n'a pas
de travail fait mendier et ça c'est la
menthe sommes surtout dans un pays qui
manque de rien
dans ce pays en grave crise
socio-économique avoir du travail semble
être devenu synonyme de steam de soi
dans les pays ciblés des vaches les gens
meurent de faim pendant les dernières
décennies des dictatures militaires et
des gouvernements néolibéraux sont
succédé aujourd'hui les russes ont
peuplé des vendeurs à la sauvette qui
des valeurs marchandises des vins du
commerce horizon définitivement fermée
est au plus bas de l'échelle les cartons
et l'os ceux qui s'emploient à récupérer
du carton du métal et divers dans les
poubelles afin de le revendre au récit
clair le gouvernement dit une chose le
lendemain il la rejette l'entière
responsabilité sur le gouvernement
il refuse les insuffisante l'aide
sociale et réclament du travail
maina détrempée
la seule aide de l'état et l'envoi de
quelques sacs de lait nature une fois
par mois
malgré cela les il n'a jamais fait ses
produits
je suis contre le gouvernement parce que
l'état privatiser les écoles deviennent
des esclaves tous les privatiser cela
on
si long qu'il vaudrait mieux
nationaliser des usines las pénaliser
les entreprises feraient rileys au lieu
de faire ce qu'il devrait y voir les
entreprises publiques aux étrangers yves
hâtives
m
alors qu'ils s'en aillent tous
comme ils disent
je pense que si le gouvernement
fournissait plus de travail les aides
sociales ne seraient plus nécessaires
et si chaque jour il ya moins de travail
alors oui il doit faire quelque chose
trouver de nouvelles sources de travail
créé des plans sociaux
je crois que personne ne veut recevoir
de l'argent sans rien faire
on n'est vraiment pas bien
et dire qu'on a connu des périodes où
nous avions tellement de travail qu'on
n'arrivait pas à tout faire
la fête
bien sûr ce sont des choses qui arrivent
partout je crois qu'à faire un
changement de gouvernement un changement
de politique
parce que vous savez une fait un pays
très riche c'est pas possible de vivre
comme ça nous avons un territoire
suffisant pour 100 millions d'habitants
alors que nous sommes même pas 1 40
milliard les politiciens nous commander
font ce qu'ils veulent
nous sommes dans cette situation
voilà
la menace
depuis les témoins ten le bandonéon a
traversé le temps comme le tonnerre a
surgi des entrailles de la terre
le bandonéon et religieux imposant et
bellini comme l'est le célèbre tango me
boileau cirus querido il s'est fait beau
banlieusards le tango est né comme ça
entre hommes dans la rue les gars se
retrouvaient pour pratiquer les pas à
l'époque les jeunes filles n'avaient pas
le droit de danser les hommes était
alors contraint de danser entre
on va lui donner
avant on se plaignait des patrons dès
maintenant
beaucoup d'entre nous n'ont qu'une
solution au problème qui existait déjà
au temps du patron pour lui manuel nous
sommes en train d'assurer pas tous un
travail un salaire et une sécurité
d'entre elles aujourd'hui on fait notre
première année d'indépendance et c'est
quelque chose de merveilleux
il ya quelques temps en france une usine
a été réquisitionné par seize ouvriers
mais n'ont pas réussi à continuer la
production alors que nous nous l'avons
fait dans une usine il ya plus de femmes
que d'hommes
tout ça ils vont violence mais il me
manque quelque chose
il nous faut peut être commencer à
penser en gros plus comme des
entrepreneurs et non seulement pour de
simples ouvriers
nous souhaitons créer une règle garderie
pour nos collègues qui ont des enfants
et qui n'ont plus de place dans les
centres aérés
ce serait génial de pouvoir faire une
crèche au 6ème étage
les libres pour le moment cela aiderait
beaucoup de collègues hommes qui vivent
seules avec leurs enfants
c'est une fuite santiago dont je me suis
va être un garçon
je me sens très de l'aude
j'ai les pieds qui gon et j'essaye de ne
pas rester trop longtemps un suisse mais
je continue venir pour rester solidaire
de mes collègues nous sommes trois fois
d'enceinte ici
il y en a qui avancent plus vite dans
cette lutte d'autres plus lentement
tu mets au couple pour le travail non
tout le monde fait la même chose que moi
après il ya des fois je viens de gardien
le samedi je viens le mal samedi matin
je viens ici pour faire attention aux
équipes qui peuvent pas des dangers
comme dès le vendredi nous paye pas dopé
la quantité des kia
et d'argent ont même fait les les années
lumière le gage de téléphone de
téléphone ne paye pas pour qu'on n'a pas
pour ne pas payer pas si c'est une
c'est beaucoup d'argent pour nous avoue
cotation
je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
hiérarchie on restera tous égaux et on
continuera à travailler en petits clubs
et ce afin qu'on a besoin d'être de
l'extérieur de gens plus compétents pour
augmenter la production
le doigt de gauche et de nouveaux
ouvriers pour justement augmenter la
productivité
suite aux manifestations des 19 et 20
décembre 2001 nous avons tourné ces
notes révèlent des femmes comme moins
qu'ils ne faisaient que travailler
élever les enfants et se couper de la
lozère nous sommes lancé mon acolyte
aujourd'hui en fait les premières
anniversaire de la manifestation où les
peuples est sorti dans la rue tous
ensemble sans dimension politique ni
social en colère contre les mesures
économiques de l'époque comme les
choralies tôt qu'il est épargné les gens
bloqués pendant plusieurs années
le peuple réclame beaucoup de casseroles
que tous les politiciens ça n'aille
qu'ils s'en aillent tous
en conséquence les présidents de
l'époque fernando de la rúa et les
ministres de l'économie cavallo
démissionne
ça c'est quelque chose de spectaculaire
le pays va mal alors et il doit se
mettre
nous espérons que tout va bien se passer
que nous aurons de la chance et que tout
se passera dans la vie
à partir du 19 20 décembre 2001 des
nouvelles formes de luttes les
organisations sociales sont donnés des
piqueteros mouvement des chômeurs
militants les assemblées populaires des
quartiers les motos queiros korcia lutte
est les saisines récupéré par ses
ouvriers
camarades parce qu'ils sont toujours ici
présents rendant hommage aux trente
mille détenus disparus et martyr de la
dernière dictature militaire et de la
guerre des malouines et aussi aux 13
camarades piqueteros assassiné lors du
19 et du 20 décembre 2001 présent
ap
accueil
avec la déléguée générale de brut man
célia martinez nous sommes ici pour
garantir un salaire un poste de travail
à tous nos ouvriers contre l'avis du
président du heat et contre celle des
patrons des syndicats qui nous ont
jamais appuyé nous sommes ici en train
de lutter ça nous coûte beaucoup
d'efforts mais grâce à vous nous avons
récupéré deux fois les usines et nous en
sommes heureux nous sommes en train de
tracer un chemin avec les camarades de
hanoi des autres usines autogéré et nous
sommes ici heureux mais comme je vous le
disais mais nous sommes aussi très
fatigué malgré tout nous avons envie de
continuer de nous battre
si nous sommes le peuple les ascendants
combative de quartier les militants des
partis politiques qui appuient cette
fête populaire qui parviendront celle
envie de lutter l'envi que nous avons de
triompher pour un pays riche pour un
poste de travail qui nous motive et non
pas juste pour un sac de nourriture nous
voulons plus encore c'est pourquoi nous
sommes ici aujourd'hui pour rendre aux
argentins ceux qui le méritent et depuis
bruckmann nous vous saluons et vous
remercions pour votre appui pendant sept
années de lutte
merci beaucoup et ensemble jusqu'à la
victoire camarades
les lettres
lusine bruckmann pro vie c'est entre
autres ou des costumes et des chemises
pour christian dior et cacharel avant de
l'homme de l'onuci
les patrons avaient licencié beaucoup de
travailleurs les cinq jours et officiels
il à rêves d'aujourd'hui 57 44 de femmes
et 13 hommes
les ouvriers publie un journal
concernant les saisines autogéré et qui
manifestaient leur lutte
elias initiatives comme par exemple la
création d'une école des métiers au sein
des big man pour aider à combattre le
chômage
sale affaire
et s'il y avait une menace réelle de
délogement elle remplir l usine de
militantes et on verrait si peuvent
toujours nous explique
nous avons beaucoup d'espoir dans
l'expropriation définitive sinon on ne
continuerait pas de se battre
nous sommes persuadés qu'avec de la
lutte et du soutien on obtiendra
l'expropriation définitive de l'usiné
nous avons l'appui de beaucoup de pays
en europe et en amérique latine
alors j'ai eu l'idée de lancer une
pétition par internet
nous recueillons des signatures et des
adhésions de gens importants et
d'intellectuels qui peuvent faire
pression sur le gouvernement ont fait
vriller on espère se représenter à la
réouverture des sessions du conseil
municipal avec des millions de
signatures qui appuient notre oeuvre
je
à
non
voilà
oui
m
lucie navi's il ne reste plus que les
vestes et les machines les chaises et
les bobines de fil une semaine avant le
premier tour des élections
présidentielles leasing recoins a été
fortement réprimé et c'est s'ouvrir et
expulsé il ya eu des centaines de
blessés dont deux députés
il soutenait les oublier dans plusieurs
pays d'europe et d'amérique latine ont
créé des associations qui collectent de
l'argent et des signatures pour les
ouvriers expulsé salaire permet de
continuer des vivres et les poursuivre
leur action
en juin 2003 quand la province de santa
fe est innocent les ouvrières
développement en propre des machines à
coudre voisins et s'installe sur les
trottoirs justin face d'eux les russes
in surveillé en permanence par la police
armée
les ouvrières pose des draps et des
couvertures pour les enfants des femmes
des jeunes des
comme si elle ne pouvait pas s'arrêter
de travailler toujours un avant le
second hier cause cause avaient tous un
suicide
lusine très très vite de ma nuit mois
les ouvrières persiste assiste aux
sessions du conseil municipal la joie
les accolades les triomphes
le conseil municipal de buenos aires à
cordes l'expropriation définitive de
l'entreprise brockmann qui deviendra une
coopérative formée par ses ouvriers
voici comment lissine qui portait
autrefois les noms des trois ex patron
brookman devient la coopérative 18
décembre les tables est bleu ciel sont
devenues un symbole des luttes et de
dignité en argentine et dans le monde
longue vie aux ouvriers saint patron
dans leur nouvelle usine